the most recognizable thing in the sky
is obviously the silhouette of the
Spitfire she's just a beautiful lady
I sure a lot of men would actually like
to marry her I'm sure they're wise
wouldn't agree there's 396 parts in a
Spitfire see how do I know that I built
it this is Martin Phillips
my name is Watson Phillips and I'm
sitting next to my Spitfire RR 2 3 2
which I'm the proud owner of Martin is
obsessed with Spitfires the big bombers
join in pounding the shoreline in the
darkest days of World War 2 Spitfires
filled the sky above England they are an
icon like freedom on wings British kids
make models of them but Martin took his
spitfire devotion to a whole nother
level for his 40th birthday
Martin's friends gave him a single
Spitfire rivet when I was presented with
this rivet the challenge was to go and
build myself a Spitfire so on the spare
at the moment not thinking I said right
I'll go out on the Monday morning and I
will build a Spitfire I never fought
that over a period of 14 years but I'd
probably wear three cars out with
mileage along the journey to provide all
the parts that you now see today two
fuel tanks they came from Norway in
Sweden some of the other parts came from
Russia some of the parts came from
Israel some of the other parts came from
Holland came from France one of the
wings was offered to us through a lost
property Department and another wing
came through a little guy coming into
work said I've got a Spitfire wing in my
garden the man-hours that go into a
project like this don't underestimate it
they are terrific and I know the blood
sweat tears that went into that after 14
years I know the question you're going
to ask me do you fly it sadly not I am
learning to fly and I hope one day to
fly it but greater guys than me fly it
my name is Matt Jones I'm a Spitfire
pilot
the modern airliners flyer 85% the speed
of sounds they got Spitfires flying at
96 97 % the speed of sound you don't get
in a Spitfire you strap it on and it
becomes a part of you because the
aeroplane means so much to so many
people there are a lot of people who
have gone down Martin's path and started
thinking they want to build a Spitfire
but I've never met anyone else who's
completed it he dedicated his life to
finding the parts he needed to get this
aeroplane flying again I went through
these 14 years had heartache than bits
didn't fit just putting it together and
finishing it and the provenance and the
journey the journey I went on you know
tears even today I cry when it runs it's
just been amazing absolutely amazing
[Music]